so i have a three-dimensional solid
right over here and i want to imagine
what type of a shape i would get if i
were to make a vertical cut and just to
refresh ourselves or give our sense of
us give us a sense of what a vertical
cut is imagine if i if this was made out
of jell-o or something kind of fairly
soft but it's still a three-dimensional
solid and i were to make a cut let's say
i were to make a cut right over here so
let's say i have this big
sharp
metal thing let me draw it like that so
you have this big sharp metal thing let
me draw a little bit neater
so you have this big sharp
metal thing that i'm going to cut
right over here so this is the thing
that i'm going to make the cut and i'm
going to go straight down this is a
vertical cut that we're talking about so
this is the thing
this is the thing that i'm going to cut
with
all right let me make it big enough
so that it can capture the shape that
will result
so this thing right over here
it's right in front
and i'm going to cut i'm going to make
it go straight down
and cut through this jello or whatever
you want to call it this this this
rectangular pyramid of jello and what
would be the resulting shape of the
intersection between that jello and this
this thing that i'm using to cut it and
now i encourage you to pause your video
and think about what the resulting shape
would be and the shape would be in two
dimensions because this this purple
surface is a two-dimensional
it's it's a two-dimensional you could
view this as part of a plane and so
where this intersects when you cut down
this rectangular pyramid is the shape
we're looking for so i encourage you to
pause the video and think about it or
try to come up with it on your own
so let's think about it and let me
let me draw
let me draw the rectangular pyramid
again
so that's the same one
and now let me see what it would look
like once i've done my cut once i've
brought this thing down
so then
so then this is where i cut
so i cut it right over here
i cut it right over here and then it'll
exit the bottom
it'll it'll cut along this it'll cut
along this side like that
cut along that side like that and then
it'll exit the bottom it'll exit the
bottom
right over there
and so
let me draw my whole thing
once i slice it down it will look like
this
it will look like this
my best shot at drawing it
it will look like this this is a
rectangular
this is a i should say this is a
vertical cut so i brought this thing
down and now the intersection between
the thing that i'm cutting with and this
this pyramid is going to be this shape
right over here it cut into the top
right over there it would get all the
way to the bottom right over there and
along this side it would cut right there
and along that side it would cut right
over there
so what's the resulting shape in two
dimensions of essentially the
intersection between the slicer and and
the jello well it would be this thing it
would look like a trapezoid let me do
that in a new color i'm overusing
i'm over using that one color
it would look it would look like a
trapezoid
so this would be the resulting shape
so the resulting shape it doesn't so the
resulting shape would look like this
would look like this
just like that if you made the cut right
over there